[موسيقى]
مساء الخير اتكلمنا في حلقه سابقه عن
اسباب الفوضى اللي بتعيشها منطقه الشرق
الاوسط وقلنا في الحلقه دي ان الشرق
الاوسط لديه اسباب ادت الى الفوضى التي
يعيشها خاصه بمنطقه الشرق الاوسط لكن كمان
في اسباب تتعلق بالعالم كله النهارده انا
بتكلم عن اسباب الفوضى التي تضرب العالم
كله هذه اللحظه السؤال ده احنا حاولنا
نجاوبه في اكثر من حلقه لكن النهارده
بنتكلم على زاويه مختلفه هذه الزاويه
المختلفه بترصد اللحظه الاستثنائيه التي
يعيشها العالم الان لماذا يعيش العالم
لحظه استثنائيه الان ببساطه في تقديره
لانه هناك
اربعه تحديات تواجه العالم في نفس اللحظه
لم يسبق للعالم في تاريخه الحديث ان واجه
هذه التحديات الاربعه مجتمعه بنفس الحده
ما هي هذه التحديات الاربعه تغير المناخي
هجوم وباقي او فيروس غير مسبوق على
البشريه
ازمات اقتصاديه ثم صراع بين القوى الكبرى
التغير المناخي اللي هو التحدي الاكبر
يعني قصه مثيره للفضول لانه لم يكن من بين
اولويات الانسان منذ سنوات قليله ثم اصبح
في بؤرته اهتمام الجميع النقب العامه
جيلي انا في اول الخمسينات اللي هو في اول
الخمسينات من العمر مثال ممتاز جدا لتطور
وعي الانسان بقضيه التغير المناخي جيلي لم
يكن يسمع عن التغير المناخي حين كنا اطفال
اول مره سمعنا عن التغير المناخي انا
شخصيا كان في سنه 1990
تحديدا بعد الغزو العراقي للكويت وقتها
كشباب كنا نتمنى ان نسمع راي الصحفي
المصري الشهير محمد حسنين هيكل عما يجري
عاوزين نسمع منه تقدير موقف ماذا سوف يحدث
للعراق وكان الراجل هيتكلم في ندوه ثانويه
بتنظمها معرض الكتاب الدولي في القاهره
وذهبنا كمجموعه من الشباب لنسمع هيكل
وكالعاده لقاءات هيكل بتبقى مزدحمه جدا
فذهبنا مبكرا ودخلنا لكن وجدنا القاعه
فارغه فجلسنا في المقاعد الاولى لكن انا
لم نجد هيكل واكتشفنا ان انا جئنا بدري
اكثر مما ينبغي وبجدنا اثنين على المنصه
اكتشفنا لاحقا انهما عالمين متخصصين في
قضايا البيئه واحد بيقول هناك ثقب في
الاوزون ولهذا الثقب سوف تكون تداعيات
خطيره على المناخ وعلى البيئه وعلى الارض
والانسان وعالم اخر بيقول له هذا كلام
فارغ في الحالتين دي كانت اول مره اسمع
فيها انا واصدقائي عن التغير المناخي وعن
الاسود
بعدها بعده سنوات بدانا نسمع من بعيد عن
التغير المناخي لكن نسمع عنه على استحياء
اكتشفت لاحقا حين يعني مع المهنه والعمل
انه حتى في ايضا في اوروبا والولايات
المتحده كان الاهتمام محدود ثم صار يتطور
بشكل كبير خصوصا في دول الغرب في الشرق
الاوسط بقى في ادراك للتغير المناخي في
السنوات الاخيره لكن ظل اهتمام العامه
محدود وده ليه اسبابه المفهومه جدا حتى
لما بيكون هناك يقين عند العامه بان
التغير المناخي مهم له اثار كبيره المشكله
في انه لما تيجي تتكلم مثلا مواطن زي
المواطن
اللبناني فتحدثه عن اثار للتغير المناخي
سوف تكون في ذروتها بعد 20 30 سنه فكان
يقول لك ما انا اصلا بلدي في حاله حرب او
مفلسه نفس القصه بالنسبه للمواطن العراقي
للمواطن اليمني دائما الحديث عن المستقبل
سلعه ليس لها زبون بين الفقراء والماذومين
طب ايه اللي تغير في السنوات الاخيره ان
الاثار التغير المناخي لم تعد منتظر خلال
سنوات المقبله ولكن اصبح اثارها الان
ملموس على كل انسان في هذه الدول وبالتالي
بقى فيه اهتمام اكبر بالتغير المناحي
باختصار انتقل الحديث والاهتمام بالتغير
المناخي من دوائر النخب ومن يعني قاعات
العلماء الى الشارع الكل بيتابع اخبار
التغير المناخي لانه بيؤثر على ارتفاع
السلع وعلى ارزاق الناس بشكل غير بشكل
مباشر
كم مثال يمكن ان اعطي له تحدثنا عن التغير
المناخي ممكن ان نقضي ثلاث ايام بنتكلم
على اثاره الملموسه الان لكن اكتفي بمثال
سريع من عدد من القارات ناخذ مثلا قاره
اسيا وناخذ العراق طب ليه العراق من قاره
اسيا لانه العراق ده كان بلد تاريخيا عنده
وفره كبيره جدا في المياه نتيجه التغير
المناخي وعوامل اخرى
النتيجه انه العراق بات يعاني من جفاف
وشفنا جميعا منذ شهور منظر غريب جدا ان
الناس بتعبر نهر دجله مرورا او سيرا على
الاقدام انه ال- ال- النهر جاف في بعض
اجزاءه في بعض فترات من السنه ده ما كانش
حادث عابر ويمر الدراسات بتقول ان العراق
على 240 ربما يصبح بلدا بلا انهار اي سوف
يجف دجله ويجف نهر الفرات
قاره افريقيا خصوصا شمال افريقيا بيعاني
من نقص شديد في المياه ومن ارتفاع كبير في
درجه حراره
المناخ يعني واثرها ملموسه جدا على كل دول
شمال افريقيا مصر ليبيا تونس الجزائر
المغرب الى اخره
الامثله همم يعني لا تقتصر على دول شمال
افريقيا احنا دايما بنسمع في الاخبار عن
العنف التطرف الارهاب في دول الساحل
الافريقي
واحد من الاسباب الرئيسيه لهذا التطرف
والعنف والتغير المناخي مثال واحد اختصارا
للوقت لما قفل بحيره تشاد الشهيره
وتقلست مساحتها لاقل من النصف تقريبا
النتيجه ان في ملايين المواطنين الافارقه
في الدول المحيطه بهذه البحيره فقدوا
ارزقهم واصبحوا فقراء النتيجه في بيئه
فيها فقر وفيها اا يعني ضعف للدوله
المركزيه النتيجه انه التطرف بتكون هذه
بيئه خصبه لانتشار التطرف والعنف الى اخره
وده قصه تستحق ان تتوقف عندها لاحقا
المساله لا تقتصر على الدول الناميه
والدول الفقيره في الشرق الاوسط وافريقيا
اوروبا في عام 2021 و22 شهدت اثار التغير
المناخي لم تشهده منذ عشرات السنوات ربما
مئات السنوات في شكل
يعني اكستريم
ويذ ريفانس او يعني صور متطرفه جدا للمناخ
ارتفاع شديد جدا في درجات الحراره او جفاف
شديد او فيضانات كبيره وشفنا على سبيل
المثال في المنتصف العام الجاري اللي هو
فين 2022 ان بعض انهار اوروبا جتت الى
درجه انه بقايا اا الحرب العالميه الثانيه
ظهرت لي العين المجرده بقايا سفن واسلحه
الى اخره
الاولاد المتحده
يعني لم تسلم من التغير المناخي
وفي مركز هناك اسمه مركز ناشيونال سانترز
ناشونال سنتريس فور ايفر
انفرميشن او المركز الوطني للمعلومات
البيئيه
المركز ده بيقدر ان الولايات المتحده في
2022 فقط من اول السنه وحتى 11 اكتوبر
للاحصائيه اللي مكتوبه يعني
الولايات المتحده واجهت على الاقل 15
كارثه كبيره
ناتجه عن التغير المناخي
والخسائر المترتبه عن كل كارثه لا تقل عن
مليار دولار وكان اخر هذه الكوارث اللي هو
اعصار الان
اعصار ايان ده ضرب والعيد في الارض ده
ولايه فلوريدا دي حاله تستحق الدراسه
لانها واحده من اكثر الولايات في امريكا
تعرضا للفيضانات والاعاصير اللي بيترتب
على كده ايه مش بقى دراسات بين العلماء في
القاعات والغرف المغلقه ده المواطن
الامريكي اللي عايش هناك على الساحل متاثر
بشكل مباشر لانه بيوتهم اتلفت ممتلكاتهم
ضاعت واصبح دلوقت انك تمتلك عقار على
السواحل على سواحل في الورده تكلفته تكلفه
التامينه ثلاث اضعاف تكلفه التامين
العاديه في باقي الولايات الامريكيه ست
شركات تامين بسبب هذه الكوارث افلست لانها
اصبحت عاجزه عن تغطيه الخسائر التي لم تكن
متوقعه في دراسات الجدوى لهذه الشركات
الخلاصه انه
التغير المناخي بات يعني امرا خطرا محدق
مش بس في تقدير العلماء ولكن يدركه العامه
في دول العالم المختلفه هذا هو التحدي
الاول
التحدي الثاني هو الهجوم الفيروسي الغير
مسبوق احنا بنعيش الان ازمه كرونه طبعا
اللي بنعاني منها من اكثر من عامين انما
ازمه كرونه دي مش اي صينيه تكيس مش حاله
استثنائيه
احنا لو رجعنا بالذاكره لل 35
يعني تذكرنا ما حدث في ال 35 40 سنه اللي
فاتت هنلاقي ان العالم بيخرج من وباء او
من فيروس ليدخل في فيروس اخر
واذكركم انه في ال 30 سنه الماضيه العالم
عانى من حوالي 35 40 سنه من الايدز فيروس
نقص المناعه البشريه ثم سارس ثم متلازمه
الشرق الاوسط التنفسيا ثم انفلونزا
الخنازير في انفلونزا الطيور زيكا ايبولا
90 والعلماء بيقولوا هذه ليست مصادفه
ما حصلش قبل كده قبل ال 30 40 سنه الماضيه
ان العالم كان بيخرج من فيروس الى فيروس
الفيروسات كانت بتهاجم ولكن على فترات
متباعده
وبيرجعوا ده لي العامل الاول التغير
المناخي لما حدث تغير مناخيري وارتفع
الدرجات حراره الارض بشكل غير مسبوق كانت
النتيجه انه البيئه الطبيعيه لكثير من
النباتات والحيوانات فاسدت واصبحت هذه
الحيوانات
والحشرات اصيبت اصلا بامراض نقلاتها
للانسان ولا تنسوا ان واحد من تفسيرات
فيروس كورونا انه انتقل من الحيوانات الى
الانسان
في علماء قلقين اكثر على ما سوف ياتي
وبيقولوا ان التغير المناخي ده وارتفاع
درجات حراره الارض سوف يؤدي الى ذوبان قتل
الثلج كما هو الحال مثلا في القطب الشمالي
وبيعتقدوا ان تحت
طبقه الثلج الموجوده في القطب الشمالي في
فيروسات محبوسه منذ الاف السنين ذوبان
الجليد قد يطلق هذه الفيروسات التي سوف
تطارد البشريه كلها
التغير المناخي والهجوم الفيروسي هم السبب
الاساسي في الازمه الاقتصاديه اللي بدات
منذ عام 2020
وذكركم انه الازمه الاقتصاديه اللي العالم
بيعيشها الان بدات بفيروس كورونا اللي ادى
لتوقف النشاط الاقتصادي
وذكركم انه لما حدث فيروس العلماء اجتمعوا
لانه الوسيله الوحيده للتخفيف من حده هذا
الوباء هو عمليه العزل بالاغلاق الاقتصادي
اوقفوا النشاط الاقتصادي الناس تقعد في
بيوتها الزموا بيوتكم كما كانوا يقولون
لنا لما كل الانسان كل الناس لازم بيوتها
كانت النتيجه ان في اندماش كبير جدا في
النشاط الاقتصادي
واذكركم ودواء الناس حلقه المختلفه سوف
اضع لكم روابطها انه النتيجه انه في بعض
الدول لما شافت ان في انحصار كبير في
النشاط الاقتصادي فكرت ان هي لو دخلت
اموال كثيره في ايدين الناس ربما يكون هذا
عامل يشجعهم على الانفاق وبالتالي تحفيظ
النشاط الاقتصادي الطريقه دي فشلت لان انت
بتدي للناس فلوس والناس اصلا عاجزه عن
مغادرات منازلهم لكن ده اللي حصل وكانت
النتيجه مثلا انه الولايات المتحده بعد
دول اوروبا حتى بعد دول منطقه الشرق
الاوسط اعطت للناس اموال كثيره اما
ليواصلوا النشاط الاقتصادي او على الاقل
اللي يستطيعوا الحصول على احتياجاتهم
خصوصا من الطبقات محدوده الدخل
الاموال اللي ضختها الحكومات والبنوك
المركزيه ظلت حديثه البنوك وحبيسه جيوب
المواطنين لان الانفال كان محدود لما بدا
يتراجع الوباء والاموال دي متوفره بدا
الانفاق يزيد خصوصا في الاسواق الكبيره
وعلى راسها الولايات المتحده بدات الطلب
يزيد بشده لكن العالم كله لم يكن قد تعافى
بعد من ازمه فيروس كورونا زي ما شرحنا في
حلقات مختلفه الموانئ لم تكن تعمل طاقتها
صفر للشحن لم تكن تعمل بكامل طاقتها
المصانع لم تكن تعمل بكامل طاقتها في
اماكن اخرى مختلفه مثل الصين والهند
وغيرها النتيجه ان بقى فيه تضخم اموال
كثيره تطارد بضائع قليله
حدث تضخم وارتفاع في الاسعار بدايه من
النصف الثاني
لاولا النصف الثاني ل 2021
فاقا من التضخم التغير المناخي تغير
المناخي يعني الوباء خلق الازمه تغير
المناخي في قيمها لان التغير المناخي ساهم
بامرين الامر الاول ان ساهم في ازمه
الطاقه اللي هي احد اهم محركات الاقتصاد
ورفع من اسعارها وبالتالي ضخم من التضخم
ازاي نتيجه التغير المناخي ارتفاع درجات
حراره الارض
والاعصير والفيضانات في اماكن والجفاف في
اماكن اخرى انه كثير من مصادر الطاقه
توقفت يعني مثلا نتيجه انه سرعه نشاط
الرياح قلت في بعض الدول العالم تاثرت اقل
لك وقله الكهرباء اللي تتولد عن الرياح
نتيجه الجفاف قلت الكهرباء اللي تتولد عن
مساقه المياه نتيجه ارتفاع درجات الحراره
تاثرت بعض محطات الطاقه النوويه كما حدث
في فرنسا ارتفاع درجات الحراره والجفاف
الشديد ادى لفاسات كثير من المحاصيل
والامثله كثيره جدا اعطيكم منها مثال واحد
فقط هو البن اللي هو يعني اشهر شرف في
العالم كله ارتفع ثمنه باكثر من 70% في
2022 لانه دول مصدره رئيسيه للبن على
راسها البرازيل تلفت المحاصيل او جزء كبير
من المحاصيل بسبب ارتفاع درجات الحراره
وبالتالي اصبح المعروض من البن محدود
وبالتالي قفزت اسعاره بامر اصبح الجميع
يدركه الرجل البسيط اللي بيعمل في قهوه
والعلماء
اذا اصبحنا امام ازمه اقتصاديه خلقها
فيروس وفاقمها التغير المناخي الازمه
الاقتصاديه ديت اخذت ثلاثه اشكال رئيسه
السبب الشكل الاولاني ازمه غذاء ال ال
الشكل الثاني ازمه الطاقه
الشكل الثالث ازمه ديون العالم
ناتج المحل الاجمالي لكل دول العالم اي لو
جمعنا اجمالي ما تنتجه كل دول العالم من
سلع وخدمات وحولناها الى قيمه نقديه هيكون
اقل من 100 مليون دولار حوالي 96 97
تريليون دولار لكن اجمال الديون على كل
دول العالم وصل الى حوالي 350 تريليون
دولار كيف ولماذا ارجعه لحلقه سابقه سوف
اضع لكم رابطها لكن اللي يهمني الان انه
اثبت الديون كانت موجوده وكان يمكن
التعامل معها وفي كل الاحوال التعامل معها
كان صعب لكن اصبح التعامل معها اصعب بكثير
بسبب الازمه اللي خلقها التغير المناخي
وال الهجوم الفيروسي لانه بقى في ازمه
اقتصاديه كبيره في شحن في في مشكله طاقه
في مشكله نقص غذاء في مشاكل كثيره جعلت
الدول التي استدنت اقل قدره على السادات
اذا اجبرت على السادات سوف تواجه مشاكل
واذا عرفت من السادات الجهات الدائنه سوف
تعاني المشاكل
ازمه التغير المناخي
ازمه الهجوم الفيروسي الازمات الاقتصاديه
المختلفه تحتاجه في علاجها لتعاون غير
مسبوق من دول العالم لحظه استثنائيه تحتاج
الى تعاون مستوى تعاون استثنائي من كل دول
العالم لكن السائد الان في العالم هو
الصراع وليست تعاون وهذا بياخذنا الى
التحدي الرابع العالم بواجه الان صراع
مفتوح ومعلن بين القوى الكبرى الصراع ده
احنا تحدثنا عنه في اكثر من حلقه ولا اريد
ان اكرر ما جاء فيها ولكن سوف اضع لكم
روابط هذه الحلقات ما يهمني الان انه
هذا الصراع
بيؤثر بشكل كبير على موازين القوه على
الاقتصاد على استقرار العالم لانه مثلا
نتيجه الصراع ما بين
القوتين الاكبر الان الولايات المتحده
وحلفائها والصين
ومعها روسيا وحلفائهما العالم بينقسم
تقريبا الى معسكرين كبيرين كل معسكر
بيحاول انه يفصل نفسه عن المعسكر الاخر
بصوره بصوره كبيره النتيجه معناها ايه
النتيجه المباشره انه العالم عاش من الحرب
العالميه الثانيه وحتى وقت قريب
يا عالم مفتوح او عالم بيو تحاول القوى
الكبرى اللي تخليه مفتوح او ما يسمى
بالعولمه تدفق رؤوس الاموال تدفق همم
الاستثمارات تعاون الدول بقدر الامكان
للحفاظ على اسواق المفتوحه مين اللي قاد
هذا النظام وارسا وشجع العالم كله عليه
الولايات المتحده منذ نهايه الحرب
العالميه الثانيه طب لماذا فعلت امريكا
ذلك لان كانت حزبتها بسيطه انا لو اسست
اسواق حره ومش بس لو اسست ده هي اساسا
ودعت وشجعت وعاقبت على من تحدى نظام السوق
العالم المفتوح
ليه لان هي كانت بعد الحرب العالميه
الثانيه كان
ناتج المحلي الاجمالي لامريكا حوالي 45%
من اقتصاد العالم فهي كانت عندها انتاج
ضخم جدا وبتبحث له عن اسواق
وتمخض العقل للاقتصاد الامريكي عن ان افضل
وسيله للحفاظ على التفوق الامريكي هو انه
العالم كله تبقى اسواق مفتوحه طب هتقول
للناس ايه اعمله نظام يفتح اسواقكم
لمنتجاتي حتى استغلكم واتفوق عليكم مش
هتقول لهم كده تقول لهم ان الجميع سوف
يستفيدوا هنا وهنا انتم تابعون لي وانا
اشتري منكم وهكذا نبيعه ونشتري وتبقى
السوق هو اللي بيحكم اذا كان والله انت
السلعك افضل مني هتبيع لي والعكس ويبقى
عوامل السوق والتنافس الجوده والسعر الى
اخره باعت الولايات المتحده هذه الفكره
لحلفائها قبل خصومها وشجعت الصين وروسيا
على الدخول في منظمه التجاره العالميه الى
اخره لكن حدث تغير في السنوات الاخيره
الماضيه تراجع الاقتصاد الامريكي نسبيا
واصبح بدل ما بيمثل 45% بيمثل حوالي 24
23%
واصبحت امريكا بتستورد اكثر مما تصدر ولم
تعد مستفيده من نظام عالمي ارثته بتتفوق
فيه الصين عليها النتيجه ان بدات الولايات
المتحده تعيد النظر في هذا النظام ولا
تريد العولمه على الاقل بهذا الشكل
اول رئيس
يتحدث عن هذا
التغير كان الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب اللي قال انه الصين تسرقنا وكيف
تسرقكم الصين قال والله انه رؤوس الاموال
الامريكيه بتذهب الى الصين لانه هناك ايد
العامله رخيصه والضرائب اقل وبالتالي
يغنون الصين ويجعلون ويخلقون طبقا متوسطه
وسط لحوالي 400 مليون صيني فيما ان العمال
والايد العامله والمواطن الامريكي البسيط
بيفقد فرص عمله وبيتحولوا الى فقراء وبدا
يغير هذا الواقع بانه يفرض همم التعريفات
جمركيه وقيود على الصادرات الصينيه
للولايات المتحده ده موقوس عن فكره
العولمه
تخيلنا ان ده كان وضع استثنائي لان ترامب
كان شخصيه استثناء ايه لكن حتى لما جاء
بيضا اللي بيمثل بافكاره وبافكار حزبه
اكبر المتحمسين للعولمه والاسواق المفتوحه
صار على خطى ترامب في هذا المجال ومش بس
عظم من القيود التي فرضتها ادارته على
الصادرات الصينيه للولايات المتحده ده همم
ساهم في وضع قيود على الصادرات الصينيه
لكل اسواق الدول الحنيفه والدول اللي
بترفض الضغوط الامريكيه لعدم استقبال سلعه
صينيه بعينيه بتتعرض لعقوبات امريكيه ثم
انتقلوا الى موقع الهجوم وليس الدفاع فبدل
من ان يفرضوا تعريفات جمركيه على الصادرات
الصينيه باتوا يمنعون صادراتهم اللي هي
بيسموها تكنولوجيا حساسه الى الصين يمنعه
الصين من الحصول مثلا على الرقائق متقدمه
منهم من خلفائهم حتى يجهزوا او يقللوا من
فرص الصين في النمو الاقتصادي والتفوق
الخلاصه ان احنا بقينا قدام معسكريين
معسكر الولايات المتحده بتقوده مع مجموعه
من حلفائها ومعسكر ابرز يعني منفيه هو
الصين ومعها دول اخرى على راسها روسيا
لكن عمليه التغيير ديه عمليه لا ندري كيف
سوف تنتهي لكن المؤكد انها بتؤدي الى
تقويض نظام استقر من حوالي سبعه عقود
وبالتالي في تغيرات كبيره يشهدها وسوف
يشهدها العالم وده احد اسباب الفوضى اللي
موجوده من الملفت للنظر ان الولايات
المتحده علشان تحافظ على سيادتها وقوتها
بدات في تقسيم العالم الى معسرين لكن كمان
هي بقت بتسعه من خلال او بهدف الحفاظ على
نفسه ان هي مش بس تقسم العالم الى
معسكريين ولكن بتسعى الى تقويه المعسكر
الاخر اولا ان هي تقلل من فرص نمو الصين
بلوه بتسعى الى تدمير بعض دول المعسكر
المعادي كما تفعل مع روسيا ومع ايران ففي
حرب اقتصاديه تبدا بتقليد قدره الصين على
النمو
تصل الى درجه تدمير الاقتصاد الروسي
وتدمير الاقتصاد الايراني وتدمير الاقتصاد
الفنزويلي كل الدول المارقه عليها
هذا التصرف له توابع وله نتائج على العالم
كله لكن امريكا بتفعل اكثر مما تفعل اكثر
من ذلك في ترغبته للحفاظ على نفسها وفي
اطار اجبار العالم على الانضمام اما الى
معسكرها او الوقوف في معسكر الدول المارقه
هي بتمارس نفوذ عنيف جدا او ضغوط شديده
جدا على حلفائها ضغوط ضاره كما فعلت مع
القاره الاوروبيه وانا بدي مثل باوروبا
لانه لو قلت مثلا دول في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط هيقولوا امريكا هكذا تفعل مع الدول
الناميه لا ده مع حلفاءها الكبار
وشاهدوا او تابعوا ما فعلته مع القاره
الاوروبيه حتى تركها همم
من خلال ادارتها للحرب الروسيه الاخرانيه
دون مراعاه المصالح الاوروبيه
لاصبحت قاره ماذومه انا الي بقول الكلام
ده عشرات المسؤولين الاوروبيين منهم وزير
ماليه فرنسا اللي قال نصا الولايات
المتحده تسعى لاضعاف القاره حتى تحكم
سيطرتها عليها ورئيس فرنسا قال كلام مشابه
واخرين الخلاصه انه نتيجه الحرب بين القوه
الكبرى العالم بيتغير وهذا التغير ربما
يسفر بعد عشرات السنوات عن عالم افضل ربما
يسر عن عالم اسود لكن المؤكد انه الان
ونحن في مرحله انتقاليه يظفر الان عن عالم
فوضوي اذا العالم بيعيش لحظه استثنائيه
لانه في اربع عوامل اجتمعت الان على
مواجهه الانسان تغير المناخي الحكومه
الفيروسي الازمات الاقتصاديه و صراع القوى
الكبرى في بعض المتفائلين بيقولوا مهما
كثره التحديات العقل الانساني قادر على
انه يجد الحلول وفي اخرين تسموهم متشائمين
او تسميهم واقعيين بيقولوا العقل الانساني
يستطيع ان يتعامل مع التحديات نعم ولكن
انا قدره لي
للانسان هناك حدود لقدره الانسان للتعامل
مع التحديات وان العقل الانساني قد يعجز
اذا واجهها مجموعه كبيره جدا من التحديات
العميقه وده اللي بيسموه الجينيو بوتينغ
انه قدره الانسان تكون اقل من مواجهه
تحديات متعدده وكثيره وعميقه فتحدث
الكوارث ماذا سوف يحدث هل يستطيع العقل
الانساني عمل مع هذه التحديات بنجاح ان
يفشل ويصبح الانسان في مواجهه فوضى
واضطرابات وشبع حرب عالميه ثالثه لننتظر
ونرى ليس في ايدينا الا ان نتابع ونشاهد
وندعو ونقول يا خفي الالطاف نجانا مما لا
خوف اشكركم والى لقاء اخر باذن الله